welcome back to cbs this morning
as nationwide protests push for racial
justice in this country
a federal appeals court is expected to
rule any day now
on whether to overturn a 44 year old
rape conviction
it happened in 1976 there were angry
protests in concord north carolina
after the conviction of a young black
man his name is ronnie wallace long
he was accused of raping a white woman
now lawyers for ronnie long who accuse
investigators of lying about evidence
are trying to write what they say is a
wrongful conviction
aaron moriarty spoke to long and his
attorney about the case
erin good morning this sounds like a
very very
upsetting and disturbing story
this is a very tough story good morning
gail
that young man is now 64. and he says he
never had a chance at a fair
trial in what was back then a mostly
segregated community
a rich wealthy white female
i mean
ronnie long was 20 years old in 1976
when he was arrested in concord north
carolina
for the rape of a 54 year old widow a
white woman by the name of sarah bost
they got the wrong man
ronnie long is absolutely innocent of
this crime
jamie lau is a professor at the duke law
innocence project
he says long who had been a talented
high school athlete
was facing a minor trespassing charge
when cops asked the victim to come to
court that day
they dressed her in a disguise brought
her to the court
room she sat there for an hour and a
half in the presence of mr long
without identifying him when long's name
was called
she identified him as the person who
assaulted her
and she later testified that she
selected him because he looked
most similar to her attacker of all the
people who were present in the courtroom
that day
but the victim had originally described
her attacker as a light-colored black
man
which long is clearly not and while a
shoe print found outside the victim's
home
had a similar tread it could not be
matched to shoes owned by long
there was also clothing including a
black leather coat
found in long's car that looked like
what the rapist
wore it was a ubiquitous piece of
clothing for black males at the time
in part because the movie shaft had come
out a few years
prior at trial long didn't take the
stand
but several alibi witnesses testified to
seeing him at the time of the rape
every moment of his day had been
accounted for
the all-white jury convicted long of
rape and burglary
he was given two life sentences i feel
like somebody had hit me with a bad
his older sister linda smith was there
for the verdict
everything just fell down because i just
knew i wasn't expecting that
she wasn't the only one concord erupted
oh my god there was a terrible sight
they went crazy they was breaking
windows they was turning over police
cars they was running all through the
street
jamie miss boss went to her death
believing that ronnie long was the man
who attacked her could she have been
that wrong
she could have and there's very clear
examples
of people believing with high levels of
confidence
that they have identified the right
attacker only to later be proven wrong
and then about 30 years after his
conviction
long's attorneys learned that
investigators had tested more than a
dozen pieces of evidence
and had hidden the results not only did
they hide evidence but then they took
the stand while
under oath and lied about the evidence
did the defense at trial know that there
were 43 fingerprints found at the crime
scene that
didn't match ronnie long they did not
did the defense know that there had
actually been a rape kit taken
and evidence taken from the victim they
did not
did the defense know that a hair that
was found at the crime scene
did not match ronnie long they did not
my reaction was oh my brother's coming
home now they don't found
elvenness but they still ain't let them
out
long's only child carlos spears was
three when his dad went to prison
he's now 47. i want the world to know
that cabarrus county locked up an
innocent man
and they need to go ahead and give him
justice but in may at a federal appeals
court the north carolina attorney
general's office argued
that none of the evidence hidden at
trial would have changed the verdict
christmas times cookouts we always miss
running somebody's missing just like a
burden carrying a burden all the time
it's really hard you know somebody's in
prison for something he didn't
do
the north carolina attorney general's
office declined to
talk about this case because it's
pending but the fourth circuit u.s court
of appeals
is expected to rule soon in the meantime
long's attorney is asking
governor roy cooper to commute long
sentence and
send him home and one other little fact
one of the
cops who worked this case actually went
to federal prison himself
for stealing checks out of the mail
anthony
43 fingerprints at the crime scene did
not match ronnie long aaron thank you
very much